اعلنت سلطات الطوارئ الروسيه اندلاعها
حريقا في منشاه اليسكي النفطيه باقليم
كراسوندار جنوبي البلاد جراه هجوم بطائره
مسيره ويعد الهجوم الثاني من نوعه على نفس
المنشاه خلال 24 ساعه بعد هجوم اخر تم
بطائره مسيره وتسبب في اندلاع حريق في احد
خزانات الوقود وتم في اوكرانيا باستمرار
وقوفها وراء هجمات ضد اهداف داخل روسيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف نفسر تصاعد وتيره
الهجمات التي تستهدف الداخل الروسي ولذلك
علاقه وهل لذلك علاقه بما اطلق عليه هجوم
الربيع الذي تحدثت عنه اوساط استخباراتيه
امريكيه وغربيه
ما دلالات هذا التصاعد في وقت تؤكد فيه
واشنطن على ثقتها في استعاده اوكرانيا
نسبه كبيره من اراضيها وهل تشهد الحرب
منعطفا استراتيجيا جديدا
كيف ستتعامل موسكو مع تصاعد الهجمات التي
تستهدف اراضيها واراضي سيطرت عليها
كالقرمرم وكيف سينعكس ذلك على جبهات
القتال المستعده شرق اوكرانيا وتحديدا
بخموت مع حديث قائد فاجنر عن نقص امدادات
سيجبر مقاتليه على الانسحاب
[موسيقى]
كرست حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا هذه الاخيره
ساحه اساسيه للحرب التي تشنها موسكو ضدك
وفيما تتحرك خطوط الاشتباك كرا وفرا على
خلفيه ذلك معززه بالتحالفات التي تقف وراء
طرفي الحرب جاءتها هجمات بالطائرات
المسيره على اهداف في الداخل الروسي لتظهر
وجها اخر للحرب الدائره ويطرح اسئله في
اكثر من اتجاه حول استراتيجيه كياف ومن
يدعمها خاصه الولايات المتحده والدول
الغربيه وكذلك بشان الرد الروسيه على
تكرار هذه الهجمات والعلاقه بين كل ذلك
والمسار العام للحربي في مجراه الاهم داخل
اوكرانيا الهجمات الاخيره جاءت في وقت
تقول فيه اكياف انها اكملت استعداداتها
لما تسميه هجوم الربيع الكبير والذي تم
الاعلان عنه منذ اسابيع روسيا من جانبها
تبدي اهتماما اشد بما قالت انه هجوم
بطائرات مسيره استهدف الكريم حيث قال وزير
الخارجيه الروسي ان صبر روسيا محدود وهي
سترد على تلك الهجمات باجراءات لم يوضح
طبيعتها
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من موسكو
خبير في الشؤون الاستراتيجيه ومن اريزونا
السفير كورت السفير الامريكي
السابق لدى حلف الناتو ومن عمان اللواء
فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
ابدا معك لواء فايزه الدويري لواء فايز ما
الذي يمكن ان نقراه في نوعيه هذه المسيرات
الاهداف التي تصل اليها ووتيره هذه
المسيرات في الفتره الاخيره
يعني هناك معادله ثنائيه اولا تطور في
القدرات في لدى الجانب الاوكراني بحيث بدا
يستخدم المسيرات وهذا من شهر حزيران من
العام الماضي عندما تم استهداف قاعده
انجلوس التي تعتبر هي احد القواعد
الرئيسيه لطائرات الاستراتيجيه ثم بدات
الغارات سواء في القرن على ميناء
سوفيستوبيل وكانت
باعداد كبيره جدا على مسافه النفط على
منصات استخراج النفط مقابل شبه جزيره
القرم وبالتالي
لا نستطيع القول ان قدرات الجانب
الاوكراني في استخدام الطائرات المسيره
بدات تتزايد بصوره واضحه وفي بعضها كانت
تصل الى عمق اكثر من 500 كيلو متر يقابل
ذلك
الشق الاخر من المعادله لا اقول فشل ولكن
اقول وجود ثغرات في منظومات الدفاع الجوي
الروسيه المسؤوله عن تامين الحمايه
للاهداف الاستراتيجيه بدءا من القبه
الزرقاء
ومرورا بكافه المناطق يعني اصبح الان
عندنا معادله تشير الى نقاط ضعف ووهن في
منظومه الدفاع الروسيه مقابل تنام القدرات
الاوكرانيه على اختراق هذه المنظومات
وتنفيذ هذه الضربات وان كانت باعداد صغيره
بفواصل زمنيه لكن الملفت ان يتم تنفيذ
عمليتين متتاليتين خلال 24 ساعه وقبلها
الوصول الى الكرمله من الناحيه العسكريه
عندما تقول من الملفت ان يتم استهداف
منشاه منشاه نفس نفس المنشاه خلال 24 ساعه
مرتين ماذا يعني ذلك
ما هو الملفت هذا يؤكد يعني الان انا قلت
هناك اهداف منتقى هناك اهداف لها علاقه
بصروره وادامه اله الحرب اهمها المنظمه
منظومه الامداد منظومه الامداد في شقين
الامداد العملياتي والامداد اللوجستي
الامداد العمليات نقاط التكديس والذخائر
وما شابه ذلك يتم التعامل معها لانها
قريبه الى الامام
بمنظومته مارس منظومات الامداد اللوجستي
او المصدر الاساسي يتمثل في مصافي النفط
وبالتالي تستخدم الطائرات المسيره اذا هو
محاوله لضرب منظومه الامداد اللوجستيه
والعمليه العملياتيه من اجل اضعاف القدره
القتاليه
للقوات الروسيه التي تقاتل خلال 24 ساعه
الماضيه تم الاعلان عن 80 هجوم من قبل
الجيش الروسي على خط على طول خط وقف اطلاق
النار اذا كقائد مقابل عليه ان يحدد نقاط
الضعف واهم نقاط الضعف وحده تعتبر اهداف
واهله هي منظومه الامداد بشنقيها العمليات
اشرت الى منظومه الامداد بشكل سريع جدا
ولكن مسيره استهدفت الكرمله
اشرت لها ولكن دعيني اقول ما جرى
بالكرمنين مدار جدال مدار
روايات متناقضه لا استطيع ان اتهم قد يكون
لدي قراءه الخاصه ولكن لا استطيع ان افصح
بها كليا ما لم يكن بين ذيل الوثائق لكن
دعيني اقول الضبابيه حول مصدر الطائره لا
يزال عليه علامه استفهام اسمع من السيده
يعني موسكو اين تضع هذه
الحجمات في اي سياق خاصه في ظل الحديث
المتزايد عن هجوم الربيع التي تعد له
اوكرانيا
هذا السؤال يجب تقسيمه على مجموعه من
الاجزاء الجزء الاول هو ان الاداره
العسكريه والسياسيه تتخذ هذه الضربات من
مسيرات بشكل جيد جدا اليوم في موسكو كان
هناك اجتماع لشخصيات محدوده من لجنه الامن
كما قيل انهم ناقشوا موضوع الهجمات على
الكريم
وترات السيد بوتين هذا الاجتماع لذلك ممكن
ان نعتقد انه سوف يكون هناك الكثير من
مستخرجات في هذا الاجتماع
بالتاكيد انهم نظروا موضوع الرد
اما بالنسبه لانتظار الهجمات الاوكرانيه
فهنا على ما افهم من الصعب ان نتحذر
ونتكهن اين سوف تبدا هذه الهجمات ولكن مما
نراه ممكن ان نقول ان حتى المصادر
الاوكرانيه ووزاره الدفاع الروسيه تستمر
بالهجوم على الجبهات التي
تعتبر فيها مستودعات للوقود وللدخيره وحيث
يتجمع الجنود الاوكرانيون حتى يقوموا
بتبطيء هذه الهجمات فاذا ساعود الى جدول
الاجتماع الذي عقد اجتماع الامن القومي
ولكن الا تدلل هذه الهجمات على ان الاخفاق
الروسي لانه جزء من المواجهه انتقل الى
داخل الاراضي الروسيه
لن اقول ان هناك اي ضعف ولكن يجب ان نقول
ان مساحه الجبهات اكثر من 2000 كيلو متر
وممكن ان تقوم اوكرانيا باطلاق اي مسيرات
من اي نقطه ولن تستطيع ان تدافع عن جميع
الحدود اذا تحدثنا عن النجاحات يجب ان
نتناسى ان هناك الكثير من المسيرات التي
دمرت قبل ان يقوموا باي اذى وحول موسكو
هناك الكثير من المسيرات التي يتم اسقاطها
ولا نعلم العدد بالتحديد ولكن ممكن ان
نقول ان انظمه الدفاع الجويه الروسيه
فعاله لدرجه كبيره سيد كارت فولدر
الاجانب الاوكراني ينفي الاتحاد الروسيه
بانه مسؤول عن بعض هذه المسيرات ماذا عن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والدول
الغربيه كيف تنظر الى هذا السلاح في
المعركه المتواصله منذ اكثر من عام سلاح
المسيرات
شكرا جزيلا اولا
نحن
لا نعلم التحديدا من هو الذي يطلق هذه
السيارات
الصوت يتقطع من المصدر هل هي تطلق من داخل
روسيا من قبل عملاء اوكرانين ام ان الروس
انفسهم يستخدمونها لتكون زريعه لمزيد من
التصعيد بساطه لا نعرف هذا من جهه اما من
جهه
الصوت يتقطع من المصدر
الولايات المتحده لا تزود اوكرانيا بسلاح
يمكن ان يضرب روسيا في الداخل
وهل هم يستخدمون معداتهم الخاصه في حربهم
هذا امر متروك لهم لكن الاثر المتحده طلبت
منهم عدم استخدام معدات امريكيه في مثل
هذه الهجمات طبعا الاوكرانيين يتعرضون
للهجوم من قبل قوات روسيه داخل اوكرانيا
ومن القوات الروسيه خارجها اذا هذا يجعل
من بعض هذه الاهداف اهدافا مشروعه عسكريا
سيتا عندما يقول وزير الخارجات الامريكي
لن نملي على اوكرانيا كيف تحافظ على
سيادتها الى ماذا يؤشر هذا الكلام هل هو
ضوء اخضر امريكي بالقيام بهذه الاعمال
هل تصف لنا موازين القوى بالنظر الى ما
يتحدث عنه الجانب الاوكراني عن اقتراب
هجوم الربيع واكتمال الاستعدادات اليه
وتطور ادوات المواجهه
يعني الان موازين القوى في البعد النظري
اذا عدنا الى قدرات الجيش الروسي ثاني جيش
في العالم وقدرات الجيش الاوكراني الذي
يقبع في نهايه التسلسل الثلاثين ثلاثينيات
او 37 كترتيب عالمي اذا نظرنا الى لغه
الاعداد نجد ان في بعض انواع الاسلحه
الطائرات على سبيل المثال الدبابات نجد ان
النسبه في بعضها واحد الى عشره بعض واحد
الى سته بعدها واحد الى ثلاث ولكن دخل
عنصر جديد وهو الاسلحه الغربيه التي تتميز
تقنيا وفي الاداء الميداني على سبيل
المثال مدافع هاوزر او هي مارس او
الباتريوت لاحقا وصول الدبابات التي لم
يظهر لها دور فعلي اذا
الحديث عن التوازن لا التوازن لا يزال
العدد لصالح القوات الروسيه النوعي بدا
يميل لصالح القوات الاوكرانيه الحديث عن
هجوم الربيع والمتوقع خلال اسبوعين الرئيس
يتحدث لن ننتظر وصول بقيه الامور التي تم
طلبها سابقا وسننفذ الهجوم بالقدرات
المتاحه حاليا هذه القدرات حتى اللحظه
التي يتحدث بها
الباحث عليه ان يجمع هذه النقاط من هنا
اربع دبابات من هنا 30 دبابه من الرقم
الاجمالي يقارب الثلاث مئه الدبابه الرقم
الاجمالي يقارب يقارب 500
قتال الرقم الاجمالي يقارب 50 طائره طائره
طائره ميج قدمت من الدول هذه القوه اذا تم
حشدها باتجاه وثق مقاربه عسكريه دقيقه
يمكن ان توجه الى نقاط الضعف وظيفك اشار
الى طول الجبهه حب ما بين 800 الى 1200
كيلو متر وتختلف من وقت الى اخر حسب شده
القتال وهناك نقاط ضعف جغرافيه محدده سواء
في غرسون او زبروجيا اذا دعيني اقول قد
يكون لدى الجيش الاوكراني القدره على شن
هجوم الربيع باتجاهات محدده من نقاط اصبحت
شبه معروفه يستطيع ان يحقق انجازات لكنه
لن يتمكن واؤكد لن يتمكن من استعاده الارض
التي سيطرت عليها القوات الروسيه بالكامل
حتى مع استثناء الحديث عن القرن وهنا اعود
مره جديده الى السيد اندريه سيد اندريه
روسيا كيف تنظر الى مسار هذه الحرب وهي
وعدت ان تكون حربا خاطفه وتحقق فيها
انجازات خلال فتره زمنيه محدوده والى حد
اليوم هي تصفها بالعمليه الخاصه
هل ترى بان مسارها يسير حسب ما تريد
اولا روسيا لم يسبق لها ان تقول ان
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه ستكون سريعه هذا
كله ما يستنتجه وسائل الاعلام وهذا جزء من
الدعايه الاعلاميه من النيتو واوكرانيا لم
تحدد روسيا
التوقيت لانتهاء العمليه العسكريه الشيء
الثاني يجب ان ننظر للنتائج ليس في
الجداول الزمنيه بل على اساس الاهداف التي
اعلنها السيد رديمير بوتين في نهاء في
بدايه العمليه العسكريه وهو نزع السلاح
الاوكراني وتغيير النظام اوكرانيا
لم تستلم اوكرانيا عفوا استخدمت الكثير من
قدراتها العسكريه وكانت اوكرانيا هي الجيش
الثاني في اوروبا بعد روسيا ولديها الكثير
من القدرات ان الاليه العسكريه الاوكرانيه
دمرت باغلبيتها وحتى الانظمه التي كانت
تستلم تدمر الكثير منها
من وجهه النظر الروسيه نرى ان توازن القوى
هو بصالح روسيا اكثر مما كان في بدايه
العام الماضي واذا نظرنا
للتعبئه الجزئيه
والمتطوعين في روسيا كذلك نرى ان هناك
درجه كبيره من تسليم الاسلحه الجديده التي
لم تكن حاضره في العام الماضي واعتقد ان
توازن القوه التي تحدث عنها السيد اللواء
فايز اعتقد ان هذا بالصالح الروسي منذ من
جانب النوعيه او من جانب التعداد سيد فانت
ذكرت بان روسيا لم تحدد مده معينه لتحقيق
اهدافها في هذه العمليه التي تصفها
بالخاصه ولكنك ذكرت اهداف هذه العمليه نزع
سلاح الاوكراني بالاضافه الى تغيير النظام
بعد عام ونصف او اكثر لم
يتحقق شيء من هذه الاهداف هل يبدو بان
الامور تسير وفقه ما تشتهيه روسيا
وصلنا الى ان اوكرانيا لم تعد كما كانت
اثناء الاتحاد السوفياتي
وبغض النظر عما تستلمه اوكرانيا
والوصول للاهداف سوف يحقق بمجرد ما يسقد
يسقط الدعم الاوروبي والغربي لاوكرانيا
وهذا سيحدث قريبا سيكرته
السيد
وما حقيقه الموقف الامريكي من هجوم الربيع
كان هنالك تشكيك من جهات خفيه امريكيه في
هذا الهجوم ثم هنالك تفاؤلا حذرا اليوم
بهذا الهجوم طبيعه حقيقه الموقف الامريكي
اعتقد انكم وصفتم الامر بالدقه بقدم ما
قلت هناك تفاعل حظر
انقطع الصوت من المصدر
هم بداوا
بالهجوم على كيف صار كيف خرسون هم خسروا
كل تلك الاراضي الان هم عادوا الى الى شبه
جزيره القرم واجزاء من دومباس وجنوب
اوكرانيا
لكنهم
يقاتلون منذ عصر طويله من دون تحقيق اي
تقدم بل منو بخسائر فادحه وهم الان يسعون
لتجنيد المزيد من
المجندين
وطبعا للاسف هناك الكثير من القتلى في
صفوف الروس عندما حاولوا تحقيق هذه
الاهداف بينما بالمقارنه اوكرانيا استطاعت
تطوير قدراته العسكريه من حيث التدريب
والمعدات اعتقد ان الضيف
اللواء قدم تقريرا وتحليلا ممتازا عن هذه
الامور وعن امكانيه قدره اوكرانيا على
استعاده معظم
بالتاكيد لن يحققوا تحرير كل اراضيهم
بحلول هات هذا العام لكن سينجحون في اجزاء
على الاقل طبعا روسيا اخفقت في اسقاط
حكومه ولم يسيطر على كل الاراضي واضح انهم
لن يحققوا هذه الاهداف اوكرانيا ستنجح
وستبقى نظاما
لو سمحت
في دقيقه لواء فايز هذا الجدل بين فاقنر
والحكومه الروسيه او الجهات الرسميه
الروسيه هل له اي تاثير على سير المعارك
على الارض في دقيقه لو سمحت
يعني هناك صراع ما بين بريجوجن ووزير
الدفاع ورئيس الاركان
تصريحات القاسيه خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه لم
يتم الرد عليها
ببيان تم الرد عليها باجراء يعني هو هدد
بالانسحاب في اليوم العاشر بعد اليوم
التاسع الاحتفال بالنشر على النازيه بدات
الجيش الروسي كانه ارسل رساله الى بريجوجن
لتنسحب الجيش الروسي موجود بدا بشن الهجوم
وادخل عنصر القوات المحموله جوا ووضع
اطارا زمنيا اذا اذا كان دقيقا سيتم
السيطره على باق موت خلال اربعه ايام
وبالتالي انا اعتبره هو صراع ما بين رئيس
مؤسس مجموعه فاغنر الطامح الى منصب وزير
الدفاع وما بين وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان
طيب اسمع منك سيدي اندريه طبيعه الرد
الروسيه على المسيرات في 30 ثانيه
ان روسيا سوف تقوي انظمتها للدفاع الجوي
وسوف تقلل القدرات الاوكرانيه على اصدار
ارسال مثل هذه المسيرات
شكرا لك سيد
خبير في الشؤون الاستراتيجيه كنت معنا من
موسكو ومن اريزونا الشكر للسيد كورت فولكر
السفير الامريكي السابق لدى حلف الناتو
ومن عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]